da dove iniziamo mascara facile dai sei
sempre stata molto brava a metterlo
quindi quindi la liga
[Musica]
perché quando visto truccando mi dovete
sempre rompere le palle
voglio fare tranquilla rilassata e ogni
tempi le mie cose sempre sempre quando
mi trucco aveva sempre dire qualcosa
guardate 6
si precisa la precisione
continua sono ritardissimo o cinque
minuti per essere pronta e perfettamente
truccata ce la devo farcela devo fare
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta abbiamo le imperfezioni un
tiro di mascara e un corso di correttore
[Musica]
questa più lunga troppo lunga
facciamo più la punta
[Musica]
andrea
mi strucco mi piace altre questioni sono
tremendi
il rossetto è sole
italo daccapo già lavata
basta pronta il bello di londra in corso
allora stamattina mi sento molto ragazza
della porta accanto quindi un look super
naturale
vorrei utilizzare il nuovo prodotto per
sopracciglia di bene di bruce tyler la
parte della polvere adesso sì che ci
siamo proprio quello che volevo
allora lo stesso promesso eyeliner pure
però manca qualcosa
potrei definire un po meglio le
sopracciglia e voglio provare la matita
in cera del bro style
questa sì che è una sopracciglia
definita e poi se non sbaglio è anche
water blue quindi posso fare la pazza
tutta la notte a bandana con il trucco
perfetto chiara non siano vista ok
quanto vorrei poi poi coi brillantini
[Musica]
quando segue sui tutorial tutti gli
chiedono dove imparò truccarmi e la sai
cosa dico fa ho fatto scuola
make up artist